well news from the tech front tonight
Amazon has announced after months of
hype that it's building two new
headquarter facilities one outside New
York City and the other outside
Washington in Arlington Virginia in
return for bestowing his grace on
America's two richest cities Jeff Bezos
who is the world's richest man will
receive more than two billion dollars in
subsidies from you the taxpayer well new
congresswoman Alexandra Acacio Cortez
had this to say today quote Amazon is a
billion dollar company the idea that it
will receive hundreds of millions of
dollars in tax breaks at a time when our
subway is crumbling and our communities
need more investment not less is
extremely concerning to residents here
hate to admit it but Alexandria Acacio
Cortez has a very good point Brian
Brenton Berg is associate professor of
business economics at the King's College
and he joins us tonight professor thank
you very much for coming on that's the
only time I've ever agreed with
Alexander Cortez but it's hard to argue
with the internal logic of her point the
richest man in the world just got two
billion dollars in taxpayer subsidies
well how does that work and he's been
shopping around the country for 14
months going to cities to see who will
give him the Bastille and he's shakin
down New York City for about one and a
half billion dollars and he's done since
something similar down in Northern
Virginia and again the whole point is
he's trying to cozy up the politicians
so that they will give him and his
company a two hundred billion dollar
company the biggest tax breaks around
and put them in a position where they
can fend off competitors for years to
come because they're cozy with the rule
makers wait so you're saying that
they're paying him to lobby them and
then you see Adam Schiff the incoming
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee saying he's going to
investigate the president for daring to
criticize Jeff Bezos oh yeah my head
spin Jeff Bezos is moving into town
because he wants to control these
narrative he wants to control what's
happening in the halls of power he's
already hired 13 million dollars worth
the lobbying and a hundred lobbyists to
deal with this now he's going to put
20,000 more people right next to DC in
Northern Virginia to make sure every
time there's an issue that affects
Amazon he has boots on the ground in the
halls of Congress in the offices of
politicians to
his his preferences past even if it
means consumers and other small
businesses lose out this is all about
getting his hands on the levers of power
can I ask you a question as an American
I should just say I'm a property owner
in the District of Columbia this makes
my property values go up I guess it's
good for me but having lived here for a
long time I can tell you the last thing
we need is more money in Washington it's
rich enough why wouldn't amazon
subsidized by taxpayers spread the
wealth maybe to Detroit or Cleveland or
Toledo or someplace that actually needs
it I don't understand because Tucker
Detroit isn't anywhere near Congress
Austin Texas isn't anywhere near
Congress Dallas whatever the city this
is purely a play for Amazon to buy
political influence they look around the
world and they see potential competitors
they like being on top and they want to
keep it that way and the way to do that
is to write the rules to write the
regulation they are buying prime real
estate where all of those rules are
written Amazon has gone from a company
that disrupts industries to a company
that stays on top behind political
influence exactly right and it's got a
whole political party protecting it it
lock it party a big business professor
thank you very much for that analysis
and bashing it